you know what Mickey we need to make
this channel more popular we need more
views more likes okay how about this 10
lit swear words in Spanish okay well how
about this idea tell your boss to go to
hell in 50 different languages what do
you mean no way that would be the
biggest video on the whole channel no
way oh wait you mean Norway sure let's
do that that'll be super popular hello
everyone welcome to the Laing focused
channel and my name is Paul like we just
decided a moment ago today's topic is
the main language of norway norwegian a
language that in many ways feels
familiar to speakers of english and
other germanic languages like Dutch and
German as I said in my video on the
North Germanic languages of the Nordic
nations Norwegian as a North Germanic
language along with Swedish and Danish
as well as Icelandic and Faroese by
around the 2nd century CE II
proto-germanic the earliest common
ancestor of all Germanic languages had
begun to branch out into Western Eastern
and northern dialects and by the 8th
century CE II the northern dialect had
developed into Old Norse spoken by the
seafaring Viking tribes
over the next six hundred years or so
Old Norse developed into the various
North Germanic languages of today
Norwegian today is spoken by around five
million people mainly in Norway as I
discuss at length in my video on the
North Germanic languages Norwegian is
very similar to neighboring Swedish and
Danish and in writing they share a high
degree of mutual intelligibility but in
speaking well it depends differences in
pronunciation and an extensive dialect
continuum that spans all three languages
make intelligibility difficult in many
cases that dialect continuum exists
within each of those three countries as
well inside Norway there are dialects
that vary greatly from each other in
most countries with lots of dialectal
variation the standard language is a
unifying force a bridge between the
various dialects but in Norway there are
two officially recognized standard
languages Luke mall which means book
language and
Nashik which means new norwegian during
the centuries-long union between Denmark
and Norway the Norwegian elite spoke a
form of Danish with their own Norwegian
pronunciation and Danish was the written
language of Norway after the end of the
Union in the 19th century a movement for
a new national language began some
people wanted to base the national
language on Danish with minor
adjustments which resulted in a written
form called League small others wanted
the national language to be more
distinctly Norwegian than Danish this
resulted in the creation of lund small a
more conservative written form which was
created using elements of various rural
norwegian dialects this was the
precursor of Nashik the norwegian
linguist eva olsen created long small he
examined the multitude of rural
norwegian dialects especially those of
western norway looking for the elements
that each dialect had preserved from old
norwegian and used those to create as
traditional a form of norwegian as
possible while still being based on its
modern dialects why did he focus on
rural dialect because the urban dialects
had been influenced by Danish while
rural dialects were more purely
Norwegian the dig small still exists in
its original form but was mostly
replaced with a slightly updated version
called boom all long small was also
replaced with a slightly updated form
called New Norcia
Luke Maul and Nina chic are more similar
than Greek small and land small were
there were plans to merge them into a
single standard called Sam nor chic but
that never happened
so now there are two standards today
local governments can choose one of the
two standards as their official form and
26% representing around 12 percent of
the population have chosen new Nashik
mostly rural communities in western
Norway around 37% have made book mall
official and 37% are neutral but in
those areas book mall tends to dominate
but everyone is also required to study
the other standard as a secondary form
these standard languages are mainly
written and when it comes to speaking
Norwegians usually use their own dialect
even in formal situations first let's
focus on boob mold and later we'll look
at Nino's
in comparison pronunciation and
orthography there are a tremendous
number of different accents in Norway
and even when pronouncing standard book
mold they will likely pronounce it in
their own accent all ways of pronouncing
Norwegian are officially considered
correct but let's focus on the
pronunciation of Oslo which sort of
serves as an unofficial pronunciation
standard consonants the pronunciation of
Norwegian consonant letters is often
different from their English equivalents
G is usually pronounced good gum but
before i i i or why it's pronounced yeah
right and the letter j is also
pronounced that way not like joe yo r is
usually an alveolar trill the odd this
is one sound that varies greatly
throughout the country it can also be an
alveolar tap and in other accents it's a
uvular fricative like ah the letter K is
pronounced before N where it would be
silent in English it's needed so unlike
the English word knife this actually
makes sense K is also associated with
some other sounds the combination KJ is
pronounced cha like in the English word
Hugh Shula so is K before E I I or Y see
noon but these days it seems that among
young people there's a growing tendency
to pronounce these as sha and I
understand that this is the source of
much controversy the letter s also
appears in some combinations to
represent the sound or approximations
thereof SJ sure skj suta and SK before
aye-aye-aye or Y sheathe some consonant
letters are silent in certain contexts
there's the letter G for example in
words ending in IG or eg daily and
before Jay yes and in some other words
like morn D is sometimes silent for
example after our L or n Tyrell or after
a long vowel goo
H is silent before J&V yelled saw the
letter T is silent in the definite form
of neuter nouns like whose and in the
neuter pronoun there and V is usually
silent after L at the end of a word
hallo long consonant double consonant
letters and clusters of consonants are
pronounced as long consonant they are
held longer than a short consonant for
example [ __ ] now compare that to this
word with a short consonant hot
this distinction occurs only in stressed
syllables there's also a distinction
between short and long vowels when a
syllable contains a long consonant it
has a short vowel hot and when a
syllable contains a short consonant it
has a long vowel hot they differ in
length but sometimes also in quality too
for example o short o stop and long o
boot I first short ceased and long see
the this vowel is long because it's in
an open syllable with no consonant at
the end
e short e 10 and long e PIM there are
some other vowels that are different
from English vowels the Norwegian Y
sound is like the sound e but with
rounded lips e lease u represents a
sound between o and e who's this letter
is like the sound F but with rounded
lips this it's also worth pointing out
two more vowels this letter used to be
common in Old English but is rare in
modern English it's been a part of
Norwegian ever since it developed from
Old Norse it represents the sound app as
in English Sat but usually comes after
are shod it's sometimes pronounced like
a this yeah this letter represents the
sound or similar to the vowel in the
English word yond the way it's
pronounced in many British accents store
most words in Norwegian have pitch
accent there's a pitch accent or a tone
chain
on the stressed syllable there are two
different tone patterns tone one is low
hi it starts on a low tone then moves to
a higher tone in the stressed syllable
tone two is high low high
it starts high but false then moves to a
higher tone in the stressed syllable the
lid the lid as you can see from the two
examples pitch accent can indicate
differences in meaning but the tones are
different depending on the dialect and
are not crucial in making yourself
understood but ignoring pitch accent
will result in a distinctly foreign
accent grammar the grammar of Norwegian
is not terribly complex and it's a
category one language according to the
American foreign service institute which
puts it in the category of languages
that are supposedly the easiest for
English speakers to learn that doesn't
mean that it's easy to learn it just
means that it's not as difficult as a
lot of other languages and that's
specifically for English speakers let's
look at a basic sentence how thick is
peas louisa this sentence means i
haven't eaten anything today
word for word 'it's i have not eaten
anything today the word order in this
sentence is exactly the same as in
english norwegians basic word order is
SVO and we can see that the verb is
conjugated in the present perfect in the
same way it is in English with the
auxiliary verb ha which means have in
the present tense followed by the past
participle of the verb Spees and also
notice that just like in English the
negation word comes between the
auxiliary verb and the past participle
but Norwegian verb conjugations are even
simpler than they are in English there
are conjugated the same regardless of
person or number so for each tense there
is only one form Spees is a regular verb
so it's a good example in the present
tense
yes piece it you can see that even
though the pronouns are different the
verb forms are all the same species also
in the simple past there's only one form
yes Beast and there's one future tense
form the other is visa there are
additional perfect and conditional
conjugations that correspond with those
in English each of them having only one
form one minor pain in the backside is
that Norwegian nouns have grammatical
gender feminine masculine and nu
for example item in the meaning a woman
in mom meaning a man that said meaning a
mountain for nouns that are not
inherently masculine or feminine like
man or woman the gender of each now
needs to be memorized but notice the
gender specific indefinite article that
comes before each noun
there are also gender specific definite
articles definite articles attached to
the end of the noun in LA the woman mom
the man seola the mountain these three
genders are used in more conservative
Norwegian and in Nino she using three
genders is required but in book mall you
can choose to treat masculine and
feminine nouns as one gender common
gender in the common gender both
feminine and masculine nouns use the
masculine form remember that people who
use book mall as their written language
may still speak dialects that are
different and may use all three genders
in speech even if they use two in
writing let's stick with the common
gender for now now let's check out the
plural forms of the nouns quinones
meaning women men meaning men cien
meaning mountains she is the same as the
singular form neuter nouns like this
that are only one syllable long usually
don't change in the plural but you can
tell that it's the plural if there's no
article second look at men this is an
irregular plural form with a change in
the vowel stem to mean this is a regular
plural form plurals of all genders
usually end in ER like this
as for the definite plural forms the
ending is in which functions as the
definite article Vilna the women men the
men fiona the mountains let's make those
nouns we just saw a little more
interesting by adding adjectives in
English in a beautiful woman in sick mom
a handsome man at HCL a tall mountain or
a high mountain the adjective to a
certain extent agrees with gender a tea
is added to the end of most adjectives
when the noun is neuter like this tea at
the end of faith and when a noun is
plural and E is added to the end of the
adjective in both the neuter and common
genders need lived in this beautiful
women sexy men and some men who you feel
tall mountains or high mountains
also when a noun phrase with an
adjective is definite there's an e at
the end of the adjective but something
else also changes there's a different
definite article then the lady in the
beautiful woman
then Sikkim on the handsome man the her
you feel the tall mountain or the high
mountain and in the plural Dean is
legend the beautiful women de set de
mañana
the handsome men do you feel the tall
mountains were the high mountains both
genders common and neuter take the same
article and the same endings on the
adjective and the noun
adjectives are also used to create
adverbs by simply using the indefinite
singular neuter form of the adjectives
like hate they usually have a T ending
though there are some exceptions as an
adverb means loudly as in at a high
volume now that we've examined some
basic features of norwegian specifically
book mall let's look at Luke mall and
Nino chic side-by-side and see how
they're different let's start with a
sentence we saw earlier in book mall
meaning I haven't eaten anything today
yeah holla kiss bees Louise oh hey Cal
[ __ ] no queer duck
these sentences don't seem so different
but there are a few differences the
first person singular subject pronoun
has a slightly different form Y ie big
similarly some of the other subject
pronouns have different forms next
notice that the negation word is spelled
differently yeah issue now notice that
the verb for eat is different in Nino
she speaks is also used but this option
it is more specific to new Nashik and
also noticed that the word for something
or anything is different
newer nuku obviously the words in book
mall and New York are often related but
with slightly different forms in spoken
dialects there are additional variations
some of which resembled nyan or shmore
in some of which resemble luke mall more
here's a sentence meaning she had a bad
dream who not then wound room who had a
wound load notice that the third person
singular feminine pronoun is different
also the masculine indefinite article is
slightly different you can also see that
the word for dream looks and sounds a
little different
Durham dome Nino she tends to preserve
more old diphthongs from Old Norse than
book mall in this way
Nino she is more like Faroese and
Icelandic than book mall or Danish or
Swedish here's a sentence meaning they
like to drive fast cars did lead it
asserted us to be live delete killer
[ __ ] Alice could be loved first the
subject pronoun is slightly different
next notice that the infinitive forms of
the verbs are slightly different shoulda
Shayla in book mall the infinitive of
most verbs ends in an unstressed e in
New York the vowel can actually be
either E or a with a being the more
conservative one now notice that the
word for cars ends in ER in book mall
and they are in New York Beal is Bella
Nino she has a tendency to use a or when
book mall uses ER though this is not
always the case
here's another sentence meaning crime is
increasing due to high unemployment
Caminos here get forget in the hurry or
bite slow said criminality [ __ ] gonna
her garbage Lisa notice the different
spelling of the verb meaning increase
including the ER and AR endings that we
just mentioned as well as a diphthong
appearing in the new northward oh good
oh yeah next notice the difference in
the way of saying due to for you to not
good enough
this way is more characteristically New
York but in New York you can also use
the same expression as in book mall
criminality and Edgar Bergen of her
garbage Lisa in book mall there is also
another form unit but it's less commonly
used notice the differences in the words
meaning unemployment or the bites
Lisette L Bates listen the word in book
mall contains the suffix head which is
used to turn adjectives into nouns but
New Norcia
generally avoids this suffix because it
reflects the influence of Danish Nino
she has a degree of linguistic purism
aiming to avoid loanwords from Danish
and German and one final pair of
sentences meaning
falling in love is common among young
people Florida's evolved Labrador Domus
for else Kinabalu cantando now notice
that the first word
neither sentence has a different ending
Nino she tends to avoid the book mall
ending Elsa which forms a noun from a
verb next we see a different spelling of
the word meaning common and again we see
the ER ending in book mall where it's a
are in new Nashik as you can see
Norwegian is a very interesting language
and if you speak a different Germanic
language then it probably seems very
familiar to you in many ways it's also a
very accessible language especially if
you focus on book mall like most
students do but when you dig a little
deeper there are many many dialects with
countless variations for you to get used
to as well as new Nashik the other form
of standard Norwegian so even though
it's an accessible language it's also a
language with a lot of depth for people
who choose to go deep the question of
the day for native speakers of Norwegian
in any of its varieties which form of
Norwegian do you most commonly use in
writing and how about in speech can you
easily communicate with people who use
other varieties and for other people
what do you think of the situation of
having two standard versions of the same
language in one country can you imagine
such a situation with your own language
if you enjoyed this video then be sure
to check out Lange focus on the various
social media platforms and as always I
want to give a special thanks to my
patreon supporters especially these ones
right here on the screen who are my top
tier patreon supporters many extra
special thanks to them and to everyone
thank you for watching and have a nice
stay
[Music]